euromaxx highlights and here's your host
cayenne hampstead now there and welcome
to our highlights of the past week and
here's a quick look at what made it into
the mix this time around musical
accompaniment mountain climbers in Italy
scale the heights to the sound of music
who's by his finest thomas gaya models
his figurines after soccer's top stars
and shadow game a greek artist presents
his sculptures in a different light and
we start off in south to roll in
northern italy for a Jazz Festival with
a difference combining sheer heights
with music in the dolomites the Czar's
launched sweet event sees lots of
hair-raising activity from BASE jumping
to slacklining all with a sultry
soundtrack of live jazz music well it's
one of the festival highlights where
music and nature are blended for a real
atmospheric thrill and we tagged along
with some extreme athletes and musicians
for the day
these musicians have spent hours
climbing to accompany a slackliner as he
completes his hair raising feet of
balance a band playing on the side of
the mountain is also there to motivate
the climbers taking on the sheer rock
face these good vibes kind of coming to
you and because sometimes you are
getting lost in your fears you know and
I think music just listening music
already helps you choose to speed and is
too small Anika we're performing a very
special score this rocky landscape and
the movements of the extreme climbers
Nick spam click them then we're playing
in the middle of this incredible
landscape with this wind the wind is one
of the biggest hurdles facing our mean
holds her one of the best slack liners
in the world 500 meters above the ground
he's struggling to balance on the thin
nylon rope monette soft hang your
success depends on your mental state in
the moment I'll fish it's very much a
psychological Thank You Louis for me it
was great that there was the faint sound
of a brass band at going through the
entire valley on the el mundo invicta he
was gone said it really motivated me
this is sean ellis was must mean what
idiot oh no climber has ever managed to
cross this overhang on the lanka for
rock face today belgian star climber
nicola address and his brother olivier
are going to attempt it as will Sean
Villanueva o'driscoll
their first attempt fails and the
climbers retreat to their bivouac for a
musical break so while climbing with a
lot of emotion because maybe it's a bit
dangerous or maybe this part that looks
very difficult and all these emotions
needs to go out of your body and like
music is a really great way of yeah
getting that emotion out on to the
second attempt
the band accompanies the action
unfolding before their eyes with an
improvised piece of music Barney tension
is almost unbearable that generates a
special energy and energy deshawn based
on the cyst it didn't let them to that
you are of course rooting for the
climbers as they're trying to scale the
overhang and the music changes
accordingly it becomes urgent because
it's almost a matter of survival but
some skip fathoms you believe it's only
a few more meters to the upper edge of
the overhang
made it
the tension was building and we're
getting more tired at the same time like
maybe even much more tired and you could
hear the song the the music getting even
crazier like oh they really felt like
they understood for our effort the
climbers celebrate their achievement
with a tune in the middle of the rock
face
and some people who are like play on the
under on the world while they climb this
cannot be extreme if that if they have
the room to play music so I think it
depends are people that are climbing for
fun and other people that climbs for
other reasons so I mean for me the main
reason is to climb for fun doesn't leave
me I'd like to do this all the time it's
much more exciting than hanging around
and stuffy jazz clubs hopefully I hope
something like this will happen all over
the North Face of Mount agha or in other
places stop feeding consoles the South
Tirol Jazz Festival has experimented
with a new type of event which offers a
thrilling combination of art and sport
in the middle of nature while dealing
with nerves is just a fact of life from
attias vodka and Michelin Calvin they do
it all in the name of art the duo from
Germany likes to hang from bridges or
scale skyscrapers to make some unusual
videos with a disturbing thrill their
son sir of course all illegal and yet
they've received multiple prizes for the
poetic quality in their work and you can
now see it on display in the send
gallery in the Austrian capital and so
we track them down to learn a bit more
about their artistic process
an excerpt from a video by artists
Matthias remke and Michelin cough one is
the subject and the other is the
cameraman the duo are not afraid to take
risks or break the law to create their
stunning shots
they'll go to almost any height in the
name of art but the stunts are not as
reckless as they look they prepare their
performances long in advance and
calculate the risks involved askim limca
up there are no safety nets in life our
works are like feedback to real life
problem sometimes we don't know what
will happen there may appear to be an
element of safety where there is not let
me film this is kaley food it's not
enough making it look dangerous it's
about seeing in the feeling when we
expose ourselves to and there are no
limits for us they discovered this world
war two flak tower in a park in Vienna
while preparing for an exhibition in the
city the site is off-limits to the
public and largely forgotten the artists
managed to gain access and add the tower
to their guerrilla performances in urban
public spaces
no but it is if there are lots of places
that aren't normally very interesting if
you're just walking past them but if you
stop and look closely you'll find lots
of interesting aspects it's consumer us
as artists it's important to see the
playful aspect and what kind of
potential this place might have aside
from its intended function often put
until they presented the results in a
video
it was featured at their first
exhibition in Vienna also on display a
photo of the tower complete with the
banner they attached to it
many of the duo's works are dangerous
and illegal but to the gallery goers the
daredevil aspect is not the essential
point
these that will go home dad it's about
the conquest of the architecture
something I see only at second or third
glance hey wait there's something
crawling on it oh that's a person he
thought the mother compet you have us
wolf does this mean once there he's
taking possession in a very tactile way
which we're not able to do because we
can only experience it visually it's
exciting from scaling smokestacks in
Prague to climbing skyscrapers in Tokyo
the performers body always becomes a
graphic element in the image a symbol in
the cityscape the compositions are
carefully thought through the danger
seems to be of secondary importance it's
been done zboost in the moment when I do
this I'm very conscious of the moment
and as i get older i enjoy these moments
more and more when i managed to make a
dream reality and to do the things that
up to then i'd only envisioned it seems
you can the foyer no bill I'm copson
the film's have a poetic serene quality
with the danger barely perceptible this
conflict is what makes the art of
Matthias remke and Michelin cough so
powerful and what has already earned
them several awards the question now is
how far this risky road will take them
this isn't an impulse we've reached a
point where things are starting to
change we're trying to reduce the images
to the essential and we've realized that
the risk aspect is getting in the way
that many viewers just can't see past
the danger and appreciate the imagery
for what it is no so we're looking for
some way to reduce that aspect and yeah
of not invited this also games
whichever way their art goes from here
the duo's daring exploits are not over
yet
exciting staffel now it's over to Poland
for a tour of the region around the
southern cities of apulia and nisa both
places date back to the Middle Ages and
there a treasure trove for tourists on
the lookout for beautiful scenery and of
course for some hearty polish cuisine so
let's see what else it's famous for opal
in Poland the city has around 120,000
residents and is the historical capital
of Upper Silesia the marketplace and the
PS tower are its landmarks the
marketplace is lined with baroque town
houses they were rebuilt after World War
2 the surrounding countryside is also a
fascinating place to visit taught both I
non I button yes diving shahnaz the
region around a pole has the largest
number of castles and palaces in all of
Poland Oh Paul is not only the capital
of the awful province it is also famous
as the capital of polish song anfiteatro
yad vashem crazy festival polski pysanky
thanks to television every pole is
familiar with the sights of the PS tower
and the amphitheater the national
festival of polish song is held here
each summer many famous singers began
their careers in opel corsa novotny's
festival it's our country's most
important festival in 2013 we celebrated
its 50th anniversary with a big gala
then the dog thermal more than 6 million
viewers watch us on television so doc
where's Donna Pearman it's a tradition
to watch the festival together voy esta
página tredici
ople province is also famous for its
porcelain in downtown opal you can find
the typical flower pattern ceramics in
every imaginable form opal exports
porcelain too many countries especially
to the Far East
it's all produced by hand
tobermory ansa every porcelain painter
has his own particular style of Mary Ann
safilo medieval if this occur it's a
kind of handwriting when you've heard of
you half an hour from opal tourists
encounter an unusual construction mozhno
castle which dates back to the 17th
century was once the home of a wealthy
aristocratic family then it served for
decades as a psychiatric hospital now
it's open to tourists yellow mazda belle
fourche lon schema Polski Polski least
many people call the castle the Polish
Disneyland okay that may sound a bit
kitschy but we like and accept this
description is now sitting in Dundee
snail and Vita wish its trevally right
beside the castle active vacationers can
go riding for about 13 euros an hour
it's a great region for riding lots of
nature that's a metaphor I like the stud
farm the atmosphere here is great the
horses are wonderful and the palace and
surroundings are beautiful pink the
zamak yet never dokie
Nissa the provinces second-largest city
lies to the south only about 20
kilometers away from the czech border it
has had a colorful history owned at
various times by poland and germany even
the french were here in 1806 the sim
jacob and agnes church is mrs. greatest
site built in the early 15th century it
was later renovated in the neo-gothic
style lyssa yeah Lisa was once called
the Rome of Silesia today we can call it
the Rome of tourists yes because
everyone finds something to his taste
here in the residents of the bishops for
it's our chance Mariska PA go DJ caruso
is najib the last stop on our tour is
bouncing an to the east of opal anissa
surrounded by nature it's primarily a
religious site st. Anne's cathedral is
home to a Franciscan Order
on important holidays the mountain
becomes a place of pilgrimage
yes miss savient cover podcast amid the
mountain has other important aspects
quarter of him it has geological
formations and flora and fauna not found
anywhere else we let our day on Mount
San dan come to a close with a typical
salesian meal beef with salesian potato
dumplings typical is a little hollow in
the potato dough it keeps the source in
the dumplings and the Alva restaurant
the servers still wear traditional
sally's in dress
Bon Appetit
tomasz gaya had long cherished the dream
of becoming a professional football
player but injury prevented him from
making that a reality and so he recycled
his passion into a profession and now he
can still kick around with his favorite
players whatever the weather Gaia is a
foosball or a kicker table designer and
he crafts all of his player figurines by
hand while that means they are each many
works of art in themselves and so our
reporter took a closer look soccer stars
from the past and present goonter netzer
sami khedira rudy fuller and paul
breitner but Thomas Gaia is growing
squad of hand crafted figurines is far
from an all-german affair he's an artist
who began making his own table football
players in 2009 this play is a buffoon
spot on oh and I was a soccer player
myself homage and I wanted to pay
tribute to these greats of the game like
Zidane Maradona the tribute to their
god-given mastery of the game hundred
fifteen he was as ever careful to give
Arsenal and Germany forward Lukas
Podolski the right hair color and
finally one last finishing touch it's
been all the beauty mark let's see how
it looks oh my view had invoked
pretty authentic soccer is a family
affair for Thomas with him and his
brother Trophy winning players in their
teens he built his first foosball table
for his younger siblings 25th birthday
Thomas assembles his tables by hand and
needs about a week to fashion each
figure his personally selected teams
includes stars from different countries
and generations the tables are works of
art hands-on and interactive
it's finding off in fact I like the look
especially the pitch that's different
from your regular foosball with just a
plain green board jaganathan they sure
you can get different club kits for
regular makes but this is something else
obviously just as easy the history of
table football goes back to the late
19th century the first patented model
appeared in 1922 where else but in
England the birthplace of soccer today
the table football industry includes
luxury models made out of mahogany and
can cost up to forty thousand euros the
figures are eerily realistic thanks to
3d printing
thomas gyres first figures were built up
with countless layers of paint he now
uses a 3d printer for the basic forms
which he then customizes his
international squad now boasts around
100 players mots women's Hut cc8 mots
Hummels a figure of himself that he
keeps in a cupboard Thomas Miller
reckoned his portrayal was a bit
unfortunate although I said it wasn't my
fault tangas are covered ss- reveal yogi
liked the figures and philipp lahm had
good things to say about Vietnam HUD COC
a booty call is that even the balls are
based on the originals that means also
creating a faithful rendition of the
current official world cup edition
thomas Gaia's miniature maestro's have
made it to a very prominent stage the
german foreign ministry in berlin the
model featured in an exhibition includes
a vintage-style ball made of leather
soccer is often touted especially in
diplomatic circles as a great tool of
cultural exchange this isn't Morty it's
a multicultural foosball table it
connects different nations here it's not
a question of one team against another
instead we have teams comprised of all
nations just having fun together ya
muhammad ananda forum and enjoying the
beautiful game is ultimately the point
on the table or on the pitch and
wherever you are in the world well he's
a former welder turned artist and
sculptor and his work only comes into
its own when the light is just right and
that's because teodosio sectio area of
greece has discovered his talent for
shadow sculpting just 18 months ago he
started building wire and metal
sculptures and from the right angle with
the right light his pieces can create
some really unexpected shapes as part of
the effect so we paid him a visit in
Athens to find out more
shadow art brings hidden forms into view
what initially looks like a tree changes
its appearance depending on where the
light comes from the man creating these
works is teodosio sectio odeya he
originally trained as a welder today he
creates sculptures from metal behind
each of them is a second work of art its
shadow
in the third me after that shadows are
everywhere but normally we hardly notice
them not that I'm very conscious of them
and see them all over the place that way
I see things that are hidden in the
object not us it's like the two sides of
a coin yeah world of Shadows is a
completely different world it has no
limits and it has its own beauty each of
odious artworks begins with a pencil and
paper he draws the future form of the
shadow and fixes it to the wall then in
semi-darkness he uses a small lamp to
construct the sculpture so that it casts
the desired shadow
who live on a la madrina first I think
about the outline it always begins with
the idea for a sculpture about the
corium mom then I consider the Parts I
need to form in the page I like to work
with metal because it is something
enduring about it in the CAF though they
miss the waffle my aim is to create
something unique that will last forever
at the visual access for the middle
sculptures are works of art in their own
right here olea has created a
three-dimensional work that casts a
shadow like Pablo Picasso's painting
Guernica the original was a political
protest against the bombing of the city
of Guernica during Spain's Civil War
1200 monotonous primero janika is
painted in black white and grey my work
with light and shadow reflects that it's
an homage to ponder Picasso canon eos in
contemporary art you see so many
installations video art performance art
i prefer the brilliant craftsmanship of
the great masters a sculpture with 350
metal spheres reminiscent of human DNA
casts the shadow of the vitruvian man
the iconic study of human proportions
Leonardo da Vinci's version is the most
famous
the artist takes inspiration from da
Vinci Michelangelo Picasso and ugly
his work cell for several thousand euros
his next shadow project involves figures
from Greek mythology his home city
Athens provides plenty of ideas
whatever but he the noise the beautiful
women the archeology Mary welcome the
whole city is inspiring you simon
osbourne we have difficult times just
now but for me the crisis is also
motivating I try to find the positive
side in it we gave me the impetus for a
new beginning a loss will make every car
Hagan algo santo de ocio sectio area an
artist who has discovered the beauty in
the dark side of things
and don't forget to visit our website if
perhaps you'd like to see some of those
reports again just go to DW de / english
/ euromaxx and happy viewing one with
that it is time for us to sign off so
until we meet again all of us from us
here in Berlin right in front of the
Brandenburg Gate toussaint Ophelia's in
person Elizabeth
you
you